not Easter Namibia most people lived
from farming Raymond kitten Baker grows
corn like many farmers here in the
region but he has a constant job on his
hands protecting his crops from hungry
neighbors we feed you don't wanna kill
you there were seven elephants as soon
as we heard that we ran out to drive
them away covino but the elephants
aren't afraid of us so they just stay
put they destroyed the fields and
suddenly our livelihood was gone we fear
for our lives but elephants and people
do largely get along here
conservationists and local authorities
have set up protected corridors allowing
the elephants to roam along age-old
routes these trails are patrolled
regularly to preempt possible problems
such as elephants crossing busy roads
yeah we are standing on the migratory
route that is coming from boots wanna to
Angola to Zambia and Angola
unfortunately dispatches the trances am
busy highway where it could be danger to
wildlife such as elephant and also
people the project is part of the
kavango Zambezi park it covers territory
in Botswana Namibia Zambia Angola and
Simba buey the park is successful
because the local people profit from the
elephants they have even set up
conservation areas outside the park so
they can earn money as we hear from
Chief Joseph my uni the community leader
protecting the elephants has created
jobs for the young people in our
community we also get a good income from
tourism from lodges and campsites then
we also have profi hunting in our area
hunting firms get licenses which also
bring us a lot of money when you too
warm around hunting and tourism provide
the main sources of income lot only
johann marx says that means local people
really value the animals over a long
period of time they can receive
financial benefit from the animals
instead of poaching them
as a result the elephants are free to
roam almost as they please even if that
does mean crossing the odd road or other
man-made obstacles